welcome everyone to our first of two
afternoon sessions my name is Dorian
more and I'm an assistant professor of
political science and public affairs
here at Columbia and we have a fantastic
panel this afternoon on case studies in
the turnaround of low performing schools
and we have some fantastic panelists one
of whom is still on his way so he will
join us and take us through this
fantastic PowerPoint presentation
momentarily but let me just briefly
introduce two of our panelists that are
here now and the third person who's on
his way first up will have Greg the feel
who is with the yes in the Department of
portfolio planning so right says so what
he's covering for right now is that the
two people from the New York City
Department of Education that we're
supposed to be here for the panel are
not here yet so I'm Greg Bethel from the
Department of Education I work in the
office of school programs and
partnerships Eric Nadel Stern who you
heard from earlier this morning is my
boss but I've spent time working with
our turnaround efforts in our division
of portfolio planning and have had some
experience in starting new schools and
thought I would do a job of pinch
hitting the sack Reagan so Greg is going
to go first he'll be followed by Alex
shubh alex is executive director of
school development at the New York City
Department of Education in this role
he's responsible for developing and
implementing a variety of school
improvement strategies focusing
primarily on opening new schools to
replace low-performing schools and the
full biles of our presenters are in your
binder so I won't go through the
extended their extended narratives and
we're also really pleased to have Alex
Schneider who is the municipal secretary
of education of Sao Paulo as secretary
he's an ease in charge of over two
thousand nine hundred schools with more
than 1 million students 82,000 employees
and a huge budget 4.2 billion dollar
budget and we're very pleased to have
him
on the panel who provide some brief
comments comparing the sau Paulo
experience in New York so first we're
going to start with Greg followed by
Alex the two Alexes somebody said
earlier they were going to speak off the
cuff and that will certainly be this
since I found out about four and a half
minutes ago that I'd be doing this I
think the most important thing to
understand we talked about case studies
of turnaround schools is that there are
lots of different visions for what it
means to turn around to school whether
that's a high school in elementary
school or middle school and I think as
you heard our chimps are talking earlier
today and the mayor some of that began
with a set of accountability changes it
had us very clearly identifying which
schools were successful with kids and
which schools were struggling and most
importantly which schools were
persistently low achieving and failing
students on a regular basis and we've
had a wave of reforms that have come
across to New York City Schools and
across the country over the last 30
years that have begun to look at what
the levers for change inside of school
organizations were we've had waves where
we've tried to make schools smaller and
more personal by doing small learning
communities in high schools and we found
out that that worked to some extent but
never really moved us over the hump of
making sure that schools really became
successful organizations you've heard a
number of references today to Michelle
Cahill and the work that's gone on here
in New York City and even as we were
talking over breakfast this morning one
of the things that really began to
change the approach to turn around in
New York City happened back in 2002 in
2003 when we really began to look at the
data telling us what our school
populations look like and what were the
factors that were really contributing to
school performance and I may get the
numbers a little bit wrong and Michelle
will certainly correct me but lots of
people think that the effort in New York
City was about going to small schools
and it turned out when we looked at
school size as a factor and whether or
not
those were high performing or low
performing school size only accounted
for about nine percent of the f of the
impact so it was not sized by itself
that made the difference but we also
knew is that when you looked at
concentrations of our lowest performing
students that that made up about twenty
one percent of the reason that schools
weren't performing but when you began to
combine together high concentrations of
our most challenging students at our
largest high schools what you started to
see that that accounted for over forty
percent of the challenge of turning
around schools and so we began a
deliberative process tied to
accountability tied to a range of other
levers that were available to begin to
identify schools that would be closed
and phased out now anybody has ever
tried to buy an apartment in New York
City knows full well the real estate
like other crowded cities is a valuable
commodity and we never really had the
luxury of simply shutting schools down
and letting them live fellow for a while
while we developed other school options
and so in New York City the only option
that we really had available to us was
to begin to face high schools down one
grade at a time we would start by not
accepting a ninth grade in the school
that was being phased out but as soon as
you begin to do that the concurrent
challenge and really what Alex will talk
about as soon as traffic in the subways
allows them to get here is that you need
to be able to replace those large
failing institutions with high
concentrations of our most challenged
students with other options and that
really is what the work of our new
schools development office has done over
time we're really fortunate here as the
mayor and the Chancellor and Eric talked
about over 250 new schools being
developed over the last eight years
really what that represents is the
developing of a pipeline of new options
that complement the replacements that we
need for the schools that were beginning
to phase out the Chancellor and others
have talked about how many of the
decisions we've made have been
controversial closing a school down is
not an easy thing for a community in
fact while we were having lunch upstairs
I found out that one of the waitstaff is
actually
graduated DeWitt Clinton High School in
the Bronx which is where my dad
graduated high school and Dima Clinton
high school is not one of the schools
that we've tried to close down over the
way certainly had its share of
challenges along the way but any time
you went to tell me or my dad that you
were going to try and close their high
school my dad hasn't been back to that
high school in over 30 or 40 years but
there's something emotional about the
process of saying that these
institutions that serve our communities
are no longer serving them well and so
there's a lot of emotion there's a lot
of anger sometimes it's tied up in that
process complementing that though has
been the new schools development process
at the same time that we're taking
something out of a community how do we
begin to bring into that community new
options that show people that closing
these schools down is not walking away
from their communities but in fact
mating a greater investment in the
options that they have available and I
think one of the quiet parts of the
reforms in New York City than anybody's
that's been on the ground has been the
energy that's been put into the new
schools development process we were
fortunate to have a range of funding
upwards of 100 million dollars that
supported that effort from the Gates
Foundation and other private
organizations along the way but the most
important ingredients that went into
that new schools process was telling a
range of community-based organizations
cultural partners around New York City
and most importantly educators in our
schools who could see for a long time
that in fact the institutions that they
were a part of we're not working for
students as well as they needed to for a
long time I taught in one of those
failing high schools I certainly thought
I worked really hard at Martin Luther
King high school for a time I was the
assistant principal there but we knew
day in and day out the students that I
thought were being served well in my
social studies class rooms if they got
the luck of having another teacher just
down the hall that wasn't as committed
or didn't have the same support or
energy or motivation that in fact that
student just by luck of the draw was not
going to have the same opportunities and
so until we started closing schools down
we didn't really get people excited
about the possibility that we could
create something different in their
place and the new schools development
process was a very deliberate process of
bringing together school leaders that
had a
for the kind of school that they wanted
to create working to support them
through the Leadership Academy and other
developmental efforts at the same time
bringing them together with community
partners that could bring intellectual
expertise capacity in many cases
resources of all types to the
collaborative process of developing new
schools and so we have campuses in the
Bronx places like Erasmus excuse me
Erasmus is out in Brooklyn i'm thinking
of Evander childs these were schools
that were graduating less than thirty
percent of their students in four years
and that's not a school than any of us
would be happy sending our students to
but as you begin to phase out a place
like Evander and replace it with schools
like computers and technology with the
principal alive name of Bruce Abramowitz
who's made real investments of personal
time and energy to bring people together
on those same campuses in much smaller
autonomous units where that principle is
responsible along with those teachers
for 400 students they would grow them
with a ninth grade class of a hundred to
108 students the next year is the school
that they were replacing phase down they
would bring on another class of students
in over four years that school would
grow to full capacity most importantly
they were growing a new culture inside
of that building those schools that
replaced that Evander for example went
from a 30-percent graduation rate to
upwards of eighty percent over a
four-year transition with many of the
same students coming from the same
community and the same families but
really reinvesting in that building not
necessarily the school organization that
was there before but using that space to
reinvent what a high-quality
high-caliber education could look like
we've done that in New York City not
just in the district public schools but
by inviting through charters and other
pieces and charters in New York City
really represent more than anything else
a contract with the state that says how
do we begin to free up an educational
institution from the bureaucracy and
many of the mandates that come with
state recognition but in exchange for
that they have a five year contract to
charter that tells them that they have
to meet certain obligations or else
there's
threatened with closure but very clearly
this portfolio that we've created in new
york city of some sixteen hundred and
eighty schools now represents a mix of
some long-standing schools places like
Brooklyn Tech Stuyvesant High School and
others that have served their
communities well for generations it
represents other schools that are still
trying to find their way some have seen
the consequences of low performance and
have really begun to improve and move
forward and others have been replaced
with schools that could begin to create
new opportunities and so there are
hundreds of stories of new schools that
have been developed there are stories of
other schools that have been motivated
to move forward and it's not a question
of large or small new or old it's really
a question have we created a culture of
excellence inside of those school
organizations and frankly we have a
challenge now in New York City and
eventually Alex will get here and talk
about it the challenge that we have is
that we can't close every school nor do
we want to close every school the
challenge is how do we close only those
schools that are our lowest performers
with the greatest challenges and replace
them with options and we move forward
but how do we also continue to support
schools that may be in the middle of the
pack and how do we make sure we help
them make their environments more
accountable more rigorous more
personalized as they're moving through
but clearly I was here in New York City
back in the 1990s I left to go out and
do national work with a national
foundation and I was attracted back to
New York City in 2008 because we had
some experience in starting new schools
and really saw a different energy that
was playing out in New York City that
really did empower educators to play a
leadership role when trying to turn
around what were unsuccessful
organizations in many places and I think
the work that's still ahead of us in New
York City is how do we continue to go
into those schools that may still be
struggling but how do we make sure that
every school in New York City is a great
school the same woman upstairs her name
was Anna who I talked about a second ago
as a middle schooler in one of our
bronze schools and she's really happy
about that option you may have heard
Joel Klein call out sin and as
the principle of Truman high school they
connected talking about how her son is
beginning to think about what his
options are and if choices are for high
school but she's also got a daughter in
second grade and isn't as happy with
what that experience has been right now
and that notion that until she has the
same choices that many of us have had to
move to other places and do other things
the working of making sure that our
neighborhood schools and really those
schools that all of our families will
send their kids to that does have to be
great options that's the work of
portfolio that's the work of new schools
development and a lot of ways to
turnaround effort is helping us make
sure we stay focused on making sure that
all of our schools are great schools
great thank you very much Greg and just
to note two things first now that we
know that you're a product of new york
city public schools what an amazing job
of contemporaneous speaking off the
cliff four minutes notice he just did to
give you a broad sense of what the
effort is like here in New York City and
something you said actually struck me
you said anytime you close down a school
is emotionally painful but arguably it's
morally necessary so we want to come
back to that in a Q&A because it is we'd
like to learn some how did you move
through those challenges of dealing with
invested community members and parents
and teachers etc knowing the pain
involved but also the opportunity and
promise of new schools at this point I'm
going to ask secretary Schneider to come
up and offer some yes please offer some
some comparisons with the school system
in South Paulo Brazil
I would like to thank for the sky
invitation and I was intended to
speaking Portuguese but i will try to do
my best in english so maybe i will
change during the presentation I was
nominated Secretary of Education of some
foul in 2006 and two things happening in
my first day the first one as the
teachers union was involved in a strike
that was the second biggest strike in
the history of the city and I am NOT a
former teacher so it was I was a strange
for them as a secretary also so when I
came to the building they were in front
of the building I went I came out of the
car and I started to talk to them and
after that I have a meeting with a
former secretary an old man who was
teacher dated some Paulo University and
he said to me the problem of bad quality
in education in Brazil that it's a
perfect crime no one is guilty about the
bad quality of our education so these
two things makes me think to work in a
reform with the teachers because when
the teachers in inside the class is
alone with the students we can make our
best in your off see but sometimes they
are alone and they have to manage this
situation so all the things that I will
talk to you and I will present to you
today was made
with our teachers in some problem so
this is some numbers we have 1 million
students some Paulo has 10.2 million
inhabitants and we have one point five
thousand schools that are administered
directly by this and we have some
schools that we finance mostly nursery
schools we put the money and they work
with the children we are responsible for
early childhood and we are responsible
also for elementary and middle education
but the state level in some power it's
difference then rio de janeiro has
around 50 percent of the responsible for
elementary and middle education in the
city of San Paulo we have just eight
high schools it's not our road to manage
the high school so we had some goals
since four years ago five years ago the
one is to improve the number of the
students and nurses cause children from
0 to 3 years it's a social problem in
our city and we had to to manage to
improve the number of childs attendant
by our system the second to increase the
school hours the Chris class size and
increase capacity when we came
eighty-five percent of our schools was
working in working in three periods of
four hours so it was difficult for the
team method schools to to manage this
situation because we had a big schools
with 1000 2000 children sitting
and it was difficult to children to
learn and to teachers to teach our class
sizes were about 40 or 35 students each
and we had also it's our major goal to
increase the results of the students and
to believe that every child can learn
and to increase the transparency so to
the parents to the society about what we
were doing to improve also
accountability of the system we've had
some actions the creation of a municipal
curriculum from nursery two middle
schools how and what the teacher had to
do in Brazil this is difficult to do
because there is the teachers and the
school's think that they they have
autonomy to do everything in the school
so we put this in March and today we
have a curriculum and they know what
they have to do and what is expected to
be learned by the children the creation
of standardized tests we didn't have
until two thousand seven a test and to
know how the children are were learning
and a fond of about thirty million
dollars is distributed among schools and
this found the the decision is of the
school and the parents on how to put
this money and pedagogical things are
some things that they want to do are
decided locally the wage of the teachers
were adjusted
increase it by more than fifty percent
above the inflection a teacher assistant
was hired to work in the first year of
the elementary schools because uh we had
a problem to end of the first grade the
first years with the literacy so we put
another teacher and a material to be
used in the class for the students and
for the teachers also the transparency
all the informations about what we do is
in internet and a special program with
the health Secretariat we have
physicians who visit the schools and to
make exams in our children and the
public system is in charge to to work
with it we have here some results the
number of children attending nursery
schools more than double from 60,000 to
132,000 in this year the number of
school hours in preschools increased
from four to six in elementary and
middle schools from four to five and
some schools have seven hours today and
it benefited 420,000 students the lemon
therrien media lab i was cooling years
increase it from eight to nine years and
we are still working to reduce the
number of silencing in per class now
they are 30 but we will progressively
reduce this number and to results that
are most important for us the school's
increase it preserves the year year by
year
and the gap between the schools with
better and lower results become thinner
so there was a big app when we started
to the measure and and now it's thinner
and all the schools are going up and the
literacy rate was increased by fifty
percent in three years and through the
introduction of the the curriculum the
test books another teacher and the first
raid negative in the first year of
elementary schools and all these things
that we do so we have a big challenge to
to improve our systems but we think that
working together with the teachers we
don't have to to agree every time but we
have to to work with them and to improve
our system and we're thinking that is
the most important lesson we had in some
problem thank you I'm sorry about my
english and last but not least we have
Alex shubh with us as well as Justin
Berra who is the chief of staff to
Deputy Commissioner sternberg who could
not join us and he'll be with us for
questions but I'm going to turn it over
to Alex for his presentation hi folks
apologize for our tardiness I see some
familiar faces thank you too Greg Beth
now for kicking at all for us if I
repeat anything that he said I apologize
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
just give an overview of the strategy we
use in the division of portfolio
planning I think the strategies we use
to turnaround schools improve
performance of our schools in general in
New York City touches on aspects of all
of the parts of the Department of
Education
our strategy begins with identification
of what works and what doesn't so that
starts with the office of accountability
and that's a separate division and they
invest tremendous time and effort into
identifying which of our schools are
performing at the highest level and
which of our schools are in need of
significant change improvement turning
around second we have our office of
enrollment and our system of student
choice which allows students to pick the
schools that they will attend
particularly at the high school level
this is essential to our strategy of
turnaround as it enables us to break the
cycle of schools that are not performing
successfully create a pipeline of
successful schools to replace those
failing schools and then give students
the option to attend the school that
they think will best fit them and their
families needs so that third part that I
just referenced is the development of
successful schools a portfolio of
strategies that we can put into all of
these locations where we really need to
improve I think I touched on all of
these aspects we also have the charter
school office and of course early
childhood so we can take our kids from a
early childhood beginning all the way
through to college readiness this really
works in a cycle and I just touched on
it but if you look at the diagram I
think you can see how these components
interact to form a coherent system so if
you start in the upper left you see
planning that's our division that
develops and implements the plans for
structural change so that's the group
that identifies where we need new
schools they look at enrollment data
they look at the performance of the
schools and they diagnose the problem
portfolio management in school
development which is the area that I run
so it's our job to find our best partner
organizations that are going to bring
school models that we think are worth
replicating to our attention and help
manage those schools for us as well as
looking for our best educators within
the system so that we can put them in
place
if you look at the box right below that
I think it's a it's a key aspect of
describing our strategy which is we
invest space and the best school
managers so we really consider we have a
system where we're we're responsible for
all of the space that we own and we are
going to invest in our best ideas by
giving people control of that space to
run their schools and then that rolls
over to the enrollment office who is
responsible for helping the kids match
to the schools that they would be most
interested in so it's quite a complex
process where each of these pieces must
be in place and and integrated in as a
whole in order for the system to work
we've been using this strategy
successfully since 2002 to phase out our
lowest performing schools and replace
them with a small school strategy many
of the schools that we have phased out
were large underperforming schools and
to speak a bit about that I mean it
sounds like my colleague was just
speaking about that but we felt the
large schools did not give the students
the attention they needed to be
successful that they had become unwieldy
that there was nobody really steering
the craft in any particular direction
and in fact it was it was very much the
example of an in action of a
bureaucratic structure rather than an
educational plan that would serve the
needs of the kids in the school and a
central piece of our strategy by
creating small schools with it would
allow the school leaders to have direct
connection to the students and
understand exactly what they needed and
be able to provide them with that I'm
sure you're familiar with chance or
clients initiative of principal
accountability and principal autonomy
central to this initiative and tied to
the small school movement is giving the
principal as much control as possible
over that school and then holding them
accountable with data rather than
tightly controlling the principal with a
series of mandates that must be
implemented the chancellor's initiative
has been centered around saying look you
all try what you think is best we've
seen your perform
since we're going to find the best
people put them in place do what you
think is going to work and then we're
going to assess what works and if it
isn't working your subject to
potentially be enclosed yourself and if
it is working keep it up so if you look
at these simple statistics we've closed
91 school since 2002 not all of the
schools that we opened have directly
replaced the schools that we closed some
have gone to underutilized space or the
new construction but the vast majority
of what you see here is part of the
replacement strategy I just want to
reference a study because it's a pretty
important validation of the work so mdrc
study was just released in june i
believe and it was a multi-year study
looking at and it was very carefully
done in that it looked at students
compared students attending the new
small schools to students that applied
and were not accepted to those small
schools through the student enrollment
process in new york city so it really
controlled for a bias that I think
people have properly identified before
people with families that are looking
for these kind of schools and even so
even with those same families and those
same students students in these schools
significantly outperformed their peers
that did not have this opportunity they
graduated at a higher rate and they
graduate graduated an even greater rate
in four years and when you consider the
number of schools that we're dealing
with here it's a significant number of
students more significantly to me and
I'll tell you just a little bit about my
background if you see the Seward Park
column there I had the good fortune to
open a school there I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about my experience
doing that in a minute but to me this is
the truly significant piece of the work
so the the shorter bars the blue bars
the darker blue bars represent the
graduation rates at many of the larger
schools that we phased out and you can
see they're typically in the 30s and 20s
very low and if you think about the
thousands of kids that were attending
those schools it really was a criminal
situation where these kids were going
nowhere and I'm not here to speak
specifically about what happens to kids
when they drop out of high school but I
think we all have a pretty good idea
and then if you look at these the aqua
bars or the taller bars those are the
amalgamated graduation rates of the
schools within the campuses so you could
see I mean they've more than doubled the
performance of the schools that they
replaced I think almost to a 1 and
that's an incredible difference so mark
sternberg our deputy chancellor for
portfolio was a principle that opened
Bronx Lab School in the Evander childs
campus and I started Essex Street
Academy in the Seward Park campus you
can see it's one of the school's
reference here I want to speak about
that experience a little bit because I
think it is important to highlight that
this strategy is dependent on an
enormous amount of work on the part of
the principles and on a Herculean effort
and I'm not here to Pat myself on the
back but i do want to indicate that the
strategy itself does not guarantee
success the hurdles in turning around
what is known as a failing campus are
extremely high from poor reputation of
the building students and families who
are not particularly interested in
bringing themselves bringing their kids
their reputations of violence actual
violence i mean i'll tell you when i
started in our first year on the Seward
Park campus it was worse than the most
exaggerated movie you ever saw about
high school there were kids smoking weed
in the school there were people fighting
in the classrooms the teachers standing
there looking I mean it was a scary
place and now if you went there I mean I
would be proud to bring you there and
take you on the tour we could cut you
loose the students would take you on a
tour it's a beautiful place but that
first year you need people who are ready
to take on that challenge I mean I ran
into the middle of fights on the street
kids swinging bottles it had nothing to
do with the contract it had nothing to
do with what I was expected to do right
the safety agents and say oh there's a
fight outside you better go deal with it
right and that was me and my staff or
nobody and if you don't have people who
are willing to go that extra mile it's
not going to work
it's not going to happen so I'm not
saying that to turn you off to this
strategy because I firmly believe in it
but I mentioned that one piece to say
you need to have a plan in place to find
folks who are willing to do that you
need to have a plan in place to motivate
those folks to take on those extra
challenges a big part of it was
chancellor client strategy of principal
empowerment and i'll tell you being told
that i was truly responsible for the
school and that i could decide how the
school would function helped me to take
responsibility for everything that would
happen there so that is one thing I can
urge you to do secondly building a
campus is a challenge in and of itself
and we have a director of campus
management who helps campus teams work
together in the Department of Education
and that's something that we have worked
on with groups of principles for a long
time but nonetheless when you take
central direct control of what should be
happening in the building away and you
have a group of people who are peers who
have to figure out what should be
happening within that building it can be
contentious and difficult arguments over
space argument over resources arguments
over passing time stairwell use all
those things can cause significant
problems and if they're not managed well
it can bring a campus down i will say i
think the department of education has
been very responsive to those issues and
has helped prevent those problems from
keeping our campuses from being
successful but if this is an initiative
you undertake to break up your larger
schools you need to be mindful of that
so building our pipeline of quality
applicants we are using two very
specific strategies now moving forward
to make sure we have the principles we
need the first is it's really based on
my experience I think our principals are
successful principles are people with
instructional knowledge I think our
successful principles are people who
have experienced working in good schools
it is a rare person not to say it cannot
happen but it is a rare person who can
step into a school and implement a
vision that they have never experienced
that they've never seen we are looking
for our
X crop of best leaders in our best
schools so using our accountability
measures that I referenced in the
beginning we're identifying our top say
hundred schools and in those hundred
schools we are asking principles to let
us know who on your staff will make a
quality principal I again along the
lines of the principal empowerment I
believe principals have the best window
onto who makes a good principle they
know they're doing the job and they can
tell us by incentivizing the
relationship between the principal and
the person they nominate by offering
financial support and incentives to the
mentor school should the person they
nominate be successful we help ensure
that one the principal is willing to
give up their best talent which is a
real impediment to people saying hey I
want my AP who's actually making my life
livable to move on and second we think
they'll nominate people they think are
going to be successful so we've just
started this program as a pilot but i
will say that eight of our strongest
applicants in this current round that
we're going through are coming through
this mentor mentor plan and i think it's
going to be a real success moving
forward second we're engaging external
organizations that have a track record
of success we are looking at their
performance and we are establishing
accountability measures I think that's
crucial in the last round of partner
developed schools the funding for those
partner organizations came from the
gates organization went directly to the
partners the partners came to us and
said here's what we want to do we mostly
said thanks you know great let's give it
a shot and I think it worked in the
sense of working with in that model of
you know let a thousand flowers bloom
and then see which ones we're going to
cut but now that the funding is coming
from the state through the Department of
Education we have the opportunity to say
to partner organizations this is what we
need you to provide for us to fund you
to open one of our schools and we want
to see one a fully thought out plan for
instruction and instructional
implementation in the school it is not
enough to say we're going to raise
standards it is not enough to say we're
going to make sure the school is well
organized you need to have a
mataji you can tell teachers this is
what we want to see you doing in the
classroom this is what effective
instruction looks like too often people
say we're going to add rigor where a
college-bound program and you say well
what is it you going to tell teachers to
do and they say be rigorous it doesn't
really tell a new teacher what to do so
we find our most effective organizations
have it thought out to we're going to
have there should be a five-minute
teacher presentation then there should
be a workshop model this is what the
workshop model should be looked like
should look like assessment should be
skill oriented etc etc and different
groups have different ideas but you can
really tell a group that knows what
they're talking about in terms of
instruction and I think you'll see that
the results they produce on line up
accordingly we're also looking for
ongoing embedded support for the
teachers being provided by the partner
organization it is not enough to have
the plan on paper to take the staff on a
weekend long retreat and then good luck
which is I think something a lot of our
schools experienced in the last round we
want someone from that partner
organization in the school in the
classrooms helping the principal to help
the teachers bring this vision to life
so how are we using this strategy to
turnaround schools we're bringing in
these partner organizations for finding
our best leaders from within New York
City Schools and we're implementing a
few of the models that you see below so
there's turn around faizan and phase out
that's where we close the larger school
typically a larger school and and slowly
grow the new school within so in case
you're unfamiliar with it it means the
school that is phasing out stops
accepting ninth graders the new school
that opened starts with only a ninth
grade class that's how I started my
school and I'll tell you a huge strength
there is when we started our school I
start with 108 ninth graders and as
difficult as it was moving into the new
building and all of the challenges that
I was describing I felt like I could
personally take on 108 children and win
which is pretty much what it was like
and that the culture I very much felt
like the culture of the school was built
by me and my you know five founding
teachers together but whenever it was
really difficult they'd all say Alex
would now
we do and really the principal is
building a culture and if you're
starting with a whole school it can be
quite difficult that said we are
interested to try turn around kids in
schools stay the same so this is a
strategy that has been described by the
federal government and by the state is
something they are hopeful that we can
try we're going to give it a shot it's
where the kids in the school all stay so
the the new incoming principal and
incoming staff and I'll talk about that
in a second would take on the the school
as a whole with an incoming ninth grade
class so that does have the added
challenge of needing to change the
culture for the kids that have been
there that is a daunting task there are
few people with the optimism and
enthusiasm willing to try this we are
going to try to New York City and we
found a few partner organizations that
has some strategies that we think could
be successful I will say it is a
holistic approach that is necessary you
must engage the community and prepare
them for the change not just internally
but externally you must have that
instructional plan figured out you must
have a plan for managing behavior in the
building aggressively and my personal
bent is that does not mean authoritarian
control it means changing often from a
failed authoritarian control structure
to one where kids are cared for and kids
are treated as human beings too often
once the school has been failing for a
long time kids have been criminalized in
those situations again that's not really
what I'm here to speak about but I think
you know what I'm referencing and that's
a difficult culture to change
transformation is our lightest touch so
oh I left something out for turnaround
kids in schools staying the same we must
turn over at least fifty percent of the
staff and that is part of that
initiative as it is written into the
grant and it is a crucial part of the
reform enabling the principal to get a
somewhat of a fresh start with their
faculty in transformation the lightest
touch if the principal has been there
for more than three years where I'll be
to change the principle there is a
significant amount of funding made
available to bring in master teachers
and turnaround teachers as identified by
our human resources department another
example of how all these initiatives
pull on all the parts of our
organization and and then there's
funding to bring in external
organizations to provide extensive
support extended day summer sessions
vacation sessions things of the like and
then restart is the turnaround phase and
phase out but using charter
organizations to replace rather than a
district model I skipped over one thing
that I just want to touch on the school
improvement grants so there's a
significant amount of money that the
state has offered up to make these
initiatives of success to the tune of 2
million dollars a building for each one
of these initiatives when they're
happening so we're very optimistic that
with this funding we should be able to
make even more dramatic improvements
than we did in the last round as you saw
in the graphs and hopefully get to where
we're providing all of our kids on a
real quality education oh thank you
thank you Alex and it was not lost on me
that and that graph he showed the school
that he started had the very highest
graduation rate so we can't pat you on
the back you can do to say
congratulations okay we have 20 minutes
or so for questions and discussion so
please if you have a question come to
the microphone in the center and
identify yourself and ask any of our
panelists questions based on the
presentations or if you'd like to share
some things from your local communities
that would be useful as well
hi my name is Susan Crawford and I have
to power to children when its twenty
nally on his fifteen still in the system
and I run something called the right to
read project and it addresses literacy
issues and so they have some questions
based directly on what your presentation
is but also have an ongoing series of
questions to each panel about what is
being done to address the literacy
problems that I'm sure you're
encountering at the high school level
and for instance the graduation rates
when I see 67% seventy two percent etc
there is about a one-third rate of
literacy throughout the country anyway
no matter what and about twenty percent
is dyslexic so what's specifically when
I see those graduation rates are the
children taking longer to graduate or
these the children's or dropping out
what particular state did you do in your
school and one other question about the
whole close that's three questions but I
ask you for three people uh-huh parents
are upset about the big busy high
schools disappearing because kids want
options they don't want to make a career
decision in eighth grade okay great
thank you okay so literacy strategies
let me start by talking about what we
did in our school and I think for us it
was an evolving being an evolving
strategy so we developed our school is a
what I would call a skilled focused we'd
a skilled focused educational plan and I
think the common core standards are kind
of coming along and now catching up to
what we invented so the the skill
focused plan we started by looking at
standards that we think kids needed to
achieve at the college level in each of
the disciplines and plan backwards so
that we would design assessments in 9th
10th 11th and 12th grade that would
guide teachers
to make sure kids were developing the
skills they needed in analyzing
literature and developing historical
arguments and doing work as a
professional scientist would using the
scientific method to answer their own
questions in using mathematical
reasoning to come up with novel answers
to problems they encounter and we
believe that if kids develop mastery
over those skills to answer new
questions or problems that they
encountered they'd be able to handle
whatever content they encountered at the
college level that it's more of a depth
versus breath approach so we started
that and we actually had tremendous
success in engaging our kids in
education a lot of certainly when we
started the school and nobody knew what
our school was people are not very
interested in coming and we got a lot of
kids over the counter as its described
who our kids that weren't place in any
school I only say that to say at a very
difficult population of kids who are
very far behind their grade level so our
approach was very successful in exciting
them about learning in demonstrating to
them that learning can be interesting in
connecting them to the idea of going to
college but i will say that while we had
over a ninety-three percent graduation
rate for that first class we tracked
their performance in college and about
fifty percent of them were not able to
do the work there and that was a
sobering realization for us I would
still have to say I was very proud of
the accomplishments of those kids and
i'll tell you when a kid comes to your
high school three or four years behind
their grade level to me the notion that
they're going to leave you in four years
having done eight years of learning
especially when there's someone who has
none of the habits or skills needed to
make that progress is a perhaps pie in
the sky however after looking at those
first results we realized we needed to
do a lot more to remediate literacy so
we did something that was somewhat
Anathem attar philosophy when we started
which was a building in assessments for
all the kids when they got to our school
leveling them we leveled our literature
programs where I'm against tracking for
all of the reasons in the literature
however my literature teachers convinced
me they said look we have kids going
through our school that never read a
book they read chapters they read
paragraphs it read parts they can't read
the books were signing because we wanted
to assign gauging difficult book so we
leveled it we added extra periods for
the kids who are performing at the
lowest levels we added teachers literacy
specialist to the staff which we didn't
have before to provide targeted
instruction and we're seeing some some
real improvement there I'll say you know
our school sort of started with the high
minded and then regressed I'd say and
not regressed as if moving backwards but
then came towards adding the remediation
many schools particularly that started
when our school started started with
double period literacy blocks and double
period math blocks to make sure that the
bulk of the students that they're
dealing with had the opportunity to
catch up and I think you may run into
you know a flipside difficulty their
parents saying well what if my child is
up to speed and now they're missing out
on art or they're missing out on these
other things that can make the high
school experience engaging but there
were so many kids who are behind that
many principals decided to go that route
secretary Schneider absolutely so
secretary Schneider is going to answer
in Portuguese so please put your
headsets on channel channel one
oh jeez well as I said in my
presentation the first thing that have
to do is to address the issues in the
first year so that we don't have
problematic students who will take the
problems ahead so the investments in the
first years besides the Greek curriculum
that we didn't have and also learning
external learning that we didn't have
was to build a structural material for
the teacher and for the student so that
they could really have their activities
so we reduced the autonomy of the
teachers that they had before on the
other hand other measures such as to
bring to the regular classes at least
one hour of reading in other words
children will have to read and we'll
have a teacher that at that time will
work with reading with children and
since we have in some problem such as an
other large cities in Brazil still a
situation of low-income generalized
low-income many of these students can't
read not only because education for my
education wasn't good but because their
parents never read and the parents never
have access to books so we formed a
specific program for our students in
which we
have built up libraries for our students
and they have to read books and that one
that they have to address in the
classroom and the other that they have
to read with their friends and families
which didn't happen before and they're
forming also reading books within the
students of the outskirts of the city of
Sao Paulo for older students who
advanced without developing a lot of
skills needed skills what we do is we
work outside of the regular classroom
hours with teachers who will work with
many students of different levels to
address their needs reading needs which
has been helping us overcome the
challenges but I think what's most
important and crucial and is to work
since early childhood so that the
students can develop their skills
throughout the years of school years
would you come up to the microphone
please and we were very short on time
someone have to ask you to be very
concise with your questions and to the
panelist as well with your answers
Thanks the question is for Alex I'm
person here from Argentina when the
scientist I work I am the educational
planning strategy director and I was
wondering to know how did you manage
teacher unions to tell them that you are
going to close schools because in my
country that is an acceptable yeah we in
CT of 10 Cyrus they have 17 teacher
unions 17 and they sit down with us and
we have to work with them but i was
wondering to know if you tell them
before you just did it great thank you
it's all yours well that's a great
question it's an ongoing it's an ongoing
issue I'd say it's a negotiation that
we're constantly involved in I mean I
think it's something that it's a
delicate it's a delicate problem I mean
we need to be respectful and mindful of
the teachers working in the schools at
the same time we have to hold the
schools to the high standards that we
want to establish for all of our kids so
while the union is there to just stand
up for their teachers and and the
Chancellor and the Department of Ed is
there to try and push the high standards
for all the kids there's bound to be
some conflict so you know they sit down
at the table and and they try to work
out agreements i think last year we hit
some bumps in the road and and this year
we're trying to be more proactive i
would say and engage folks in a more
meaningful conversation to make sure
that we you know can find the right
compromises but i don't think there's an
easy answer and i should say that
teachers unions are strong here in the
US and in New York I think they're
strongest in the world in Argentina so
you have a you know really deeper
challenges and stronger challenges in
that regard Greg wanted to answer this
question as well more practical I think
it's really important to distinguish
between the teachers and the teachers
union and there are 80,000 teachers in
New York City many of them not happy
about the conditions that they're
working in and I think one of the
important things that I think we could
have done better and I think Alex and
the team of portfolio are working on now
this was never a conversation about the
teachers and their failures this was a
conversation about the conditions that
existed on these campuses that despite
how hard people were working the
trajectory for success was nearly
impossible because of those
concentrations we were talking
about earlier so I think one of the key
things and we started to see it as we
started to get momentum around the
effort the issue was how through this
process of phase out and starting new
schools did we create better conditions
for teachers to work in that they would
begin to value and then I mean the
reality is over 300 schools now in the
city are being taught by unionized
teachers working under the same contract
but with a core belief that this the new
settings they've created or where they
want to be and so I think early
communication is important but it can't
start out as a battle between management
and the unions it's got to start out
based on the data with an
acknowledgement that the work we've been
doing together is not serving the
interests of students and their families
well and the question is how do we move
forward from from there and I think we
had some early missed steps to Joel's
point earlier that the boldness of the
effort was making sure that we stayed
focused on having to do something
different but I think the process that
we have this year is doing a better job
of engaging a broader range of community
stakeholders working more closely with
the unions and one of the important
things that happened early on it was in
the contract for schools that we phased
out the new schools coming in were
required to interview at least fifty
percent of the teachers to see whether
or not they were good fits for that new
school coming in so it wasn't simply
about moving those teachers out of the
way and if we treat teachers like
professionals and work with them in this
process we go a long way but at the same
time we can't compromise to your point
or other Dorian about the moral
imperative with this it isn't about the
teachers it's not about us as
administrators it's about the set of
outcomes the matter for kids thirty
percent to eighty percent is proof that
this work can work can we do it better
and engaging people as we're going
forward with that certainly great please
I'll try and keep it to Rufus boss for
Mike Walter I'm assistant deputy
minister
from Edmonton Alberta Canada and I just
want to be clear on your definition of
closure just sold on the same wavelength
are you saying that the school is empty
the building is shut down and all kids
are transferred to another facility no
that's not so that is one of the four
strategies that's been identified by
this state and the federal government
but know what I was referring to is what
we call phase in and phase out where you
bring in a new school and the school
that was there already stops taking in
new students no no because the new
school that you put in there will grow
into the space so often if it was a
really large school we might put several
schools in that will grow and fill the
space as we did in the campus I worked
I'm gonna jump in and see if I can
clarify this for our international
friends here because I think this is
part of the answer to the issue of the
union issue from a legal point of view
New York City closes schools precisely
it's not the only reason but precisely
because that gives them a new
opportunity to start over again so the
building may be the same and in fact the
students in the school may be largely
the same it depends upon the model
that's put into place as Alex was
pointing out earlier but the issue as it
relates to the law in New York and
that's the critical variable here that
distinguishes what's going on in New
York from some of the International
examples of 17 Union sitting down is
this turns out to be a very interesting
strategy that has allowed New York to
turn over some really lousy schools bad
performing schools and deal with the
legal constraints that some of the
teachers union earlier contracts had
imposed upon the school system not
talking about teachers but talking about
negotiated contracts so you know let's
be clear about that since we're sharing
best practices among friends this was a
strategy based upon the law that gives
us an offer
to start over again in some of the
neighborhood schools that were the
lowest performing schools and get really
good schools in neighborhoods that have
been starved of these schools for 50
years and they're not all charters most
of them are actually neighborhood-based
public schools but but we had to close
the school literally in order to give us
an opportunity to start over again I
think that if that law wasn't on the
books we would have a different kind of
strategy in place to deal with would
turn over and change and frankly to get
rid of low performing principles and low
performing teachers in this context as
well so it's something for everybody to
think about it's the legal constraints
that you have in your system and how to
get around them frankly if that's what
you have to do thank you great Thank You
professor Fuchs last question good
evening everybody I'm monta from India
New Delhi my question is that what are
the measurable parameters you decided
when you said low performing schools was
it only the dropout rate and you said
the number of graduate students and
anything else what were the measurable
parameters my first question so our
accountability system in New York takes
a number of things into account I mean
it's a relatively complex thing but I'll
try and summarize it to the best of my
ability so I think one really important
measure is that three-fourths of a
school's accountability are based on
comparing it to schools within its peer
group and those peer groups are
established based on performance of the
students coming in on earlier exams so a
fourth of the school's performance is
based on its comparative performance to
the city and three-fourths to schools
that have a similar population to it and
then there's a variety of categories
that are looked at to make up the
school's grade its attendance a survey
that's filled out by students teachers
and parents about how they feel the
school is doing in terms of
communicating with them academic rigor
and a variety of other categories then
there's graduation rates and
different measures of graduation there's
bonus points available for the
performance of students in the lowest
third and then there's the progress that
students are making in terms of how many
credits they're earning year to year and
again bonus points for the performance
of students in the lowest third so those
are the major categories that make up
what we call the school progress report
and that is the first piece of
information we use to determine if
schools should be on our list to
investigate foreclosure after that we
have anecdotal reports from the network
leaders and cluster leaders who are
people that work closely with the
schools and then finally we look at the
demand for the school based on
enrollment trends and schools in the
area and whether we have the capacity to
close a school meaning will we be able
to cite those students elsewhere do we
need another school there etc Chris
secretary Schneider did you want to
respond to this now just one comment in
Brazil like in Argentina is against the
law some strategies that you've made
here especially the sticks no fire
teachers or filled out schools so I
would like to ask you about the
character that you you use as a
strategies also because we are
discussing just the sticks years but
maybe there are carrots on soon there
are some carrots but they're like those
baby carrots you so I mean there's
incentive pay that our performance pay
that is given to principles if their
schools perform in the highest levels
and if the school is too well year after
year to me the biggest incentive though
is simply the autonomy the principals
have to decide on the instructional
program in their school as long as their
school continues to perform well getting
free of that tight district control was
an
liberation for me as an educator and
it's what made me interested in being a
principal after being a teacher in an
assistant principal where I felt like we
were ducking all the time you know so
those are the main ones that came home
for me great we are out of time and we
want to make sure you're alert for the
very next session so please join me in
thanking all of our panelists Greg both
eel Justin Berra Alex shubh and
secretary Schneider